foreign
I'm a senior scientist here at the
Simons Institute for the theory of
computing I will just make a few brief
remarks before handing it over to
Workshop organizers a quick introduction
to the Simon's Institute
um so this is the leading international
venue for collaborative research and
theoretical computer science it was
established in 2012 with a generous
Grant from the Simon's foundation and
every semester of the foundation The
Institute brings together the world's
leading researchers in the theory of
computing and related fields as well as
the next generation of outstanding young
scholars and we typically run two
programs each semester each bringing
together about 70 researchers Junior and
senior and each of these includes a boot
camp and a few workshops typically three
workshops that bring more visitors here
and I would like you to welcome uh you
to the the workshop and structure of
constraints in sequential decision
making which is a third of four
workshops in the Masters program on data
driven decision process last week there
was a joint Workshop which was an extra
Workshop in this program and I would
really like to thank the organizers for
their hard work in putting together an
exciting program this week and they are
Shipra Agarwal and balusiman and they
will give more important remarks about
the workshop shortly
thanks
again
and quick Logistics about the coming
week food is provided before the first
talk outside and also during the breaks
and for lunch you are on your own but
there are many excellent options in the
vicinity and we ask that you please
leave food and you know coffee and such
outside at the auditorium it helps us
um water and Bottles is fine and if you
want to leave your stuff while going out
for lunch there are lockers and the
others you know on the other side and
you can lock your bags um and our
videographer Omer Farr will help
speakers set up for talks in case you
have any issues and finally I would like
to give a special thanks for our events
team kelani Ashley and Elizabeth for
managing all the logistics for this
week's Workshop including accommodations
for all the out of town business so with
this I'll hand over things to the
organizers at League Shipra will say a
few words
thanks and have a great week
is it
um yeah
thank you and welcome everyone good
morning
um so just a few words about this
Workshop so we are this is a third
Workshop as did we mentioned on
structure of constraints and secretary
decision making we have one more
workshop on the societal consideration
so I'll just have a word about that
Workshop before talking about this which
is that that Workshop is soliciting um
posters so the deadline is this Friday
so if you're interested or students or
others who might be interested please
pass this message okay so we have 16
exciting talks for this Workshop we went
with a one-hour long talks so hopefully
you know we don't just get the statement
of the results from the talks but you
know some proof techniques and some nice
interactions that's the goal so the 16
talks will go as uh four talks on Monday
and Tuesday three talks on Wednesday and
Thursday and two talks on Friday we
learned early on Friday half a day
um so you know Mondays and Tuesdays will
be 9 30 to 10 30 11 to 12 half an hour
break Network lunch break two to three
and three Thirty to 4 30. uh Wednesday
we'll have only three talks that's
because after the two to three PM
session we'll have a poster session and
similarly Thursday we'll only have three
talks that's because after the 3pm
session there'll be an open problem
session so please do uh prepare some
open problems uh and add it to the doc
which I've sent
and uh yeah Friday we'll end half a day
rocks
um
and today uh after the 4 30 that is
after the four talks the final topic
since at 4 30 there will be a reception
uh Peter barter technician event so
we'll all head over to that after this
talk
um I think that's it
just for open problems I just want to
emphasize if you if you just want to
shoot us an email that's also fine or
better ad into the dark or character
similar to the breaks and mention your
ideas
yeah any format is fine like we expect
to do at least like 10 minutes for each
of the photos so there is hopefully some
discussion not just the statement of the
problem
okay good I guess we can begin the first
Topic in front on constant to database
thanks
thank you the talk is about constant
regret in exchangeable action models and
this is a class of problems a class of
settings that I've been thinking about
for a few years now uh with some
fantastic collaborators the main focus
of the talk today will be on work with
kamasi and sit in fact if some of you
went to sits talk on Friday at least
some of the ideas you would see today
might seem at least somewhat familiar
now I want to do the following today's
talk I want to start by defining
exchangeable action models or the
exchangeable mdps as a class of problems
and sort of make clear what sort of
things we would include in that and what
would not count as an exchangeable
action model
then I will try to characterize sets of
assumptions where we can achieve uniform
loss guarantees where we can achieve
constant regret that will not scale with
the time Horizon of our problem set
and in particular that will relate both
to the types of objectives that we're
facing the types of constraints that
we're facing the types of information
structures that we're facing and then I
will try to give some algorithmic and
analytic ideas of how an algorithm
actually achieves such constant regret
and how one can prove such constant
regrets and uh and finally hopefully I
will have time to then point to some
actual applications of this to problems
that we might be interested in where we
can then get new guarantees
um as I said I want to start by defining
exchangeable action mdps so the setting
that I'm considering is one where we
have extra exogenous arrivals over a
Time Horizon of lengths T so we have
Theta 1 Theta 2 up to Theta t and we
have a constant number of possible
arrivals
in each period we observe the arrival
and we take in a revocable action
I should highlight whenever you see the
lightning that's an indicator for danger
that means I'm treating something as a
constant and how constant this is
depends on the particular lightning but
they're all going to look the same but
you should treat this as
okay when he says constant regret he
does not care about the size of K he
does not care about the size of L for L
it's probably often innocent
the actions might be accept reject
that's innocent that just two for K it
might be larger
so we have our exogenous arrivals in
each period we observed one and we take
an irrevocable action
and we will denote by X Theta J the
number of times over our T periods that
there's an arrival of type Theta and we
take action J
and now
what I would want for an exchangeable
action model is that the objective can
be written as a function f of x which I
either want to maximize or minimize
for some known function f
so I know the function f
I don't know
the arrivals
and I want my objective to only be a
function of how often did I take each
action
some of you might think
why would it only be a function of that
basically the sort of problem I'm
excluding is one where there's a Time
dependency where it makes a difference
whether I take a particular action in
Period three or in Period 24. I'm
assuming it does not if a particular
type arrives and you take a particular
action in response to that type it's the
same regardless of when that occurs
now I'll make some assumptions on F I'll
also make some assumptions on the
arrivals but I first want to sort of
highlight the problems that would be
captured in here
the first that I'm interested in is
online stochastic band packing
so we have bins of a given size for
example let's assume our bins have size
10.
and our items
are our arrivals are items of different
sizes for example the sizes could be one
three four five and eight
and in each period we observe some item
and we need to either place it into one
of the existing bins
or we need to create a new bin and put
it into the new bin
we can think of the bins as sort of
being configurations of bins so for
example 118 would be a configuration it
means that is a bin where we want two
items of size one and one item of size
eight one four five
one item of size one one of size four
one of size five and so forth if we
denote by B Theta J
um this greater equal to one I think
should actually be a greater equal to
zero now that I think about it the
number of items of a particular size
that fits into a configuration
so
b555
the configuration with two fives in it
can hold two items of size five
if we then denote by X data the X Theta
J the number of times that we take the
action a Theta J then the total number
of bins that we are going to be using
can be written as f of x being equal to
the sum over all different
configurations
the maximum over all types of X data J
divided by B Theta J take the ceiling of
that
yes
because you assume that it costs itself
say again like you assume that you have
such special types of the beams right
but you are saying that because I have
constant number of types it doesn't
matter yes
um but
actually can you repeat can you say like
a normal bin packing as I know it I
don't have fixed types of bins they can
change types as long as you go uh yes
here you fix the types yes so I fixed
the types of the bits and I'm also
fixing the the sizes
um
but yeah other than that it's normal
uh for those of you for whom the ceiling
is unnatural
not so important all that really matters
is our objective here is a function of X
and only of X it's not a function of
when you take a particular action it's
only a function of how often did you
take each action
now different example Network Revenue
management we have some resources
and our arrivals come with a value and a
resource requirement
so our values
uh scalars our resource requirements are
in the same Dimension as our resources
that we have available
and in each period we observe a type and
need to either accept or reject
and we want to maximize the accepted
values without violating resource
constraints
because I later want for my objective
function to actually be continuous
rather than setting a hard constraint or
not violating the resource constraints
what I will do is I will penalize any
violation of the resource constraints
and other than that I'm just maximizing
the value that I achieved from all the
types that I've accepted
notice in particular we again have an
objective that's only a function of X
it's not a function of how we got to
that when we accept it or rejected a
particular type
similar you can think of models of job
assignments there's a choice between M
servers for each arrival each arrival is
a job that needs to be processed and the
decision is which server do we want to
be process it at
um denote by X data J the number of
times that you sent a type Theta job to
a type J server and let's say our
objective is the cost to process our
jobs where each server has both for each
job a fixed cost
C Theta J and the minimum average cost
per job MJ
um and you will get something like this
here this is a bit unusual for
a job assignment model this was actually
the original sort of the first problem
in this class that I was thinking about
in a particular online platform
application
in Refugee placement which is an area of
study that's
sort of become a neat application of
optimization in recent years
you have Refugee centers placement
centers where refugees sort of first
arrive in a host country
and a refugee resettlement agencies need
to make a decision of where should a
refugee be sent when they arrive to a
host country so the arrivals are now
cases of refugees
um the metric of interest is the
probability or the expected number of
refugees that will find employment in
the house host country so this is our
probability V Theta J for employment
this comes from some machine learning
model that is already given
and then in each period we observe a
case we need to take an irrevocable
action of telling a refugee this is the
center that you've been assigned to
and by X data J we would denote the
number of times that a case with a
particular employment Vector of
probability is assigned to a particular
location and our objective would again
be to maximize the employment
where we are penalizing resource uh via
capacity violations in the same way as
before meaning each of the centers has a
capacity and we don't want to send more
people to that Center then we have
capacity for
in this case what is
that Theta would be so if you think
about the machine learning model it
predicts the employment of the arrival
for
um so a person comes in the machine
learning model tells me you have a
probability of 0.8 of finding employment
here and probability of 0.2 or finding
employment there
and that would characterize the type
so it's like they're
we can think of it as preference but
preference is actually not what matters
what matters is sort of the probability
of finding employment
uh this is worked at uh
yes so for each one based on the number
of covariates that these resettlement
agencies have access to there is a
prediction of their ability to find
employment in different locations
yes you can think of it as a you can
think of it as a vector where each J
each location J
is indexed by
uh is is given by V the datably
foreign
s clearly that are captured here
it's worth highlighting things that are
not captured
so one thing that's not captured in
particular is any sort of Bandit setting
so
if I have an arrival in a bandit setting
I pull an arm and I don't know what the
outcome will be that's sort of the whole
point of the
explore exploit aspect of it
here I assume that f is no
so whenever the objective is unknown
that's going to be a bit tricky yes so
is this basically the full information
thing where
before placement you have this type
Theta that's only information that
hindsight to meet the optimal decision
so this F function depends on the
sequence of the whole thetas
and then you made the assumption that it
depends on the actions in such a way
that it depends on the actions through
their frequences on it that's it yes
that's the full information setting is
this monster yes and you don't
necessarily know the arrivals beforehand
and that's where the good complication
comes from online learning but the in
terms of like if you knew the arrivals
the problem would be trivia yes
um another thing that's not captured is
exactly when our actions are time
sensitive so right now I believe we'll
be talking uh after this talk about a
setting where we do been packing but the
size of the job sort of varies across
time
and that's definitely not captured
because without having seen her exact
talk I'm pretty sure in that setting the
timing of actions becomes important so
objective depends not just on the number
of times we take each action but also on
when we take them
this
another thing that's not quite captured
at least as stated now which is the
overbooking setting which is weird
because I used overbooking in the title
of the talk so I better be able to
capture it so in overbooking I claim
that I don't quite know the function as
let me explain why
the traditional overbooking model for a
resource allocation would look something
like this we have arrivals that give us
some value if they're accepted
but they also have some probability to
be no shows
and no shows are great because if we
accept them they will pay but they won't
actually consume any resources they
won't show up
think of this as being the reason why
Airlines might overbook a flight
in particular this would incentivize us
to admit more arrivals than we have
resources for
because I get more money and I don't
actually need to have more seats
available because those people don't
shop anyway
now the problem is if I accept too many
people so that even the people who do
show up consume more resources than I've
available then I'll need to pay a
penalty for each person that I've
overbooked
now
when I admit a type I don't know whether
they will show up
so if you think about it
I have all these arrivals
there's a particular arrival of a
particular type
at times seven at period seven I have an
arrival of a particular type and I
accepted them and that one
actually ends up showing up three
periods later there's another arrival of
the same type that one is a no-show
eventually I I'll never find out because
I rejected them if I'd done it the other
way around
my objective would have been different
because the person would have been a
notion
so
in a way I don't know F exactly because
F depends not only on the actions I take
but also in the realization of the no
showness which I don't know
now if I knew all of the arrivals who
would should I be accepting
by arrivals I mean that type I don't
mean their realization if I knew the
realizations it's sort of a silly
problem just accept all the people who
don't show up get the money without them
ever showing up it's great
now I claim this here should be the
expression that I'd want to accept
the maximum value that I get from
accepting people minus the penalty in
expectation of who will or won't show up
and if I pretend that this is my
objective
then it actually becomes an exchangeable
action model
now that's not the real objective that's
just the expected objective in a sense
but if I use this as my objective I can
then compare myself with a clairvoyant
for example which is what we'll end up
doing with the Clairvoyant who knows all
of the arrivals but doesn't know the
realizations
so in that sense even though over
booking a priori might not be viewed as
an exchangeable action model once you
take this view of the world
which still gives you an upper bound on
the best possible
policy
and you get an exchangeable action model
now
this was a quick overview of a number of
different models that would fit into the
setting of exchangeable actions
from now onwards for the most part I
will actually steer away from any
particular example and I will try to
make everything that I say relate to all
of these examples
The Benchmark that I'll be interested in
throughout is that of a clairvoyant
Optimum
meaning
the optimal solution that you would get
from your actions
if you knew all of the arrivals
beforehand so what am I optimizing here
I'm saying opt is equal to the maximum f
of x
subject to for every arrival type if you
look at all the actions that you take
you want to be equal to n Theta of T and
Theta of T is the number of arrivals of
and of type Theta over the entire time
Horizon
and of course I'm not allowing any
action to be taken negatively so that
will be my Benchmark this is basically
what you would get if you were solving
the problem offline with all the
information beforehand
and what I would like for my algorithms
objective to to be like is I would like
the gap between this Optimum this
Clairvoyant Optimum and my algorithm to
be bounded by a constant
and of course there's a lightning there
because I'm okay with this constant
depending on any lightning that you've
seen before in any way
I just don't want it to depend on t t
being the time Horizon
um one thing that's worth mentioning
is that for all the problems I've
described so far
it turns out that it's sort of trivial
to get square root T loss
in the as with the assumptions that we
will be making
so
getting squarity is really not of
Interest getting a 20 of 1 is hopefully
where we'll see some interesting things
happening
now in order to make some assumptions I
want to be clear
I sort of have a family of assumptions I
have sets of assumptions and you can
pick and choose and depending on how you
pick and choose I might be able to say
no it's impossible to get constant loss
or I might be able to say yes you can
get constant loss that way
[Music]
does it depend on
Theta 1 to Theta T and not just on the
number of each frequency
and in part because the algorithm's
actions might depend
on what the algorithm has seen so far so
if you think of an algorithm that
doesn't know a priori the probability of
each arrival
that algorithm would actually have to
learn initially what the probabilities
are the actions might be different
depending on the arrival sequence
with the optimum
should also actually be a function of
the optimum I guess should be a function
of the counts
or you're saying that it doesn't help
them
so possible assumptions
um there are two settings I can allow
with respect to the time Horizon one is
easy and pretty standard I know the time
Horizon approx
the other is a new one that we've come
up with that uh I actually think is a
very natural one that people might want
to consider more in other settings as
well
T is a priori unknown
but sometime before the end of the time
Horizon we get a warning we're told the
time Horizon is going to end
so I don't know anything about the time
Horizon a probably
I don't know how it's distributed it can
effectively be chosen adversarially
but
when the end is coming up I'm sort of
given a signal
now notice I don't need the signal to be
super far before the end
I'm putting in t to the three quarters
here it could actually be as small as t
to the one-half plus Epsilon for some
Epsilon greater zero but that would
force me to carry the Epsilon for a lot
of the torque which I don't want to do
so instead I'm just going to plug in
epsilon equal to one quarter
so I'm basically allowing for an
adversarial end to the time Horizon as
long as I get a warning sometime before
that when might this be applicable
imagine there's an open-ended marketing
campaign that we started at the
beginning of this semester
which was in mid-august and now today we
are told by our manager actually on
Friday the marketing campaign will end
so rather than being told turn it off
right now
we're told at the end of the week it's
going to be over that doesn't strike me
as unnatural
if that was the case
in reality what we would be getting is
sort of a heads up of this flavor
and more natural maybe to a computer
science audience version of this
would be our Rivals come in batches
and we don't know how many batches there
will be but what we do know is that our
batches
are all fairly large
and when the last batch arrives we are
told this is the last batch
so either one of these would basically
fall into this assumption
um
it's sort of an assumption that I find
when we first came up with it
um maybe it seemed
sort of unnatural at this point I'm sort
of convinced that this is actually the
natural one and either adversarial or a
priority known is less natural
um so
after two years I've very much gotten
used to this being what the real world
looks like
um I realize most of the audience will
probably disagree with me for another
two years maybe in two years you will
see it similarly
um possible assumptions on arrivals
notice I can
um I can accommodate a whole range sort
of depends on which one you want
um one would be our Rivals are IID
each uh type has a probability P Theta
that needs to be bounded below by a
constant
um there's my lightning
um
it might be independent with known sort
of probabilities in each period
um
it might be IID was known P Theta this
is strictly weaker than this one and we
can get computationally a bit better
results if we do this
we can also handle having just a single
sample of tier Rivals as long as we know
that it's drawn from a distribution and
the distribution has certain properties
uh I don't think I'll actually go into
the details on this one but think of uh
A1 as maybe being the one I will focus
on the most which might also be sort of
the
most standard one
now most importantly assumptions on F
um I will make four assumptions on app
and the first one is genuinely innocent
I need my function app to be Lipschitz
continuous
sort of makes sense if like if I take a
single wrong action that should not
curse me like that that should not be
like the end of
achieving what I'd like to achieve
um the second one
looks a bit weird
but it's actually not that weird
what it's basically saying is
give me two different vectors of
arrivals
and take an optimal solution under one
of the arrival vectors
I want it to be the case that under the
other arrival vectors
the existing optimal solution that is
not too far away
that sounds weird
but when f for example can be written as
an LP
then it's actually always fulfilled by
some linear perturbation results from
the 80s
for overbooking
it's actually
much harder to show this
um because for overbooking we have a
concave objective
from this expectation that is non-linear
and
we only have such a result for concave
objectives that have strong curvature
and the overbooking objective doesn't
have strong curvature
so
there we had to develop a whole lot of
Machinery I'll talk a little bit about
that in a bit
but the point is this looks surprising
but it's actually not that
crazy it actually holds in a lot of
settings
so the last two
um are a bit more art
one is
if we have an open-ended marketing
campaign
in order to have the ability of getting
any sort of decent result I need my
function to be homogeneous
if I have an open-ended timer rise and I
don't know when it's going to end
I want to achieve constant regret
I need it to be the case that my uh
objective function will be homogeneous
in the time Horizon
another one
is uh and this one is actually the one
I'm sort of least happy with uh because
this is the one that I don't actually
provably know that it's necessary uh
we need the existence of either a unique
Optimum or we need the objectives to be
concave this doesn't hold in all
settings that we consider but in some of
them it does
and informally speaking our results can
be summarized as follows if you take the
right combination of the assumptions
that I just gave you you can get
constant loss if you drop one of them
then you cannot get constant loss
now what are the right combinations is
in F or uh I do so but in a way that
keeps it looks just continuous so
basically I want to penalize violations
rather than
um
uh actually setting it to Infinity
that in some cases when I know the time
Horizon
I can always avoid violating the
constraints in the examples I'm thinking
about at least when I don't know the
time Horizon uh
I would get an impossibility otherwise
like in when I don't know the time
Horizon it's necessary to to do
basically to do the uh penalizations
all right so we want to get to the
uniform loss and we're starting over
here for any results that I'm showing I
will need exchangeable eye actions I
will need the Lipschitz continuity I
will need the the stability of the
optimal solution assumption
but now there are different Paths of
getting there when I know the Horizon I
know the arrival sequence uh not the
arrival sequence but the distribution
and its IID
then by doing some resolving log lot T
times I can get to
uniform loss
when it's known and independent I need
to resolve some more often
but I still get my uniform loss
when it's unknown IID I need to resolve
do the resolving step a lot more often
but I can still get to uniform loss
when the Horizon is unknown I need the
homogeneity for sure
I can handle unknown IID I need to add
the concave assumption which I don't
love because I haven't yet figured out
how to get rid of it and I need to
resolve T times
or if it's known IID sort of I'm
basically back in the setting up here
and it's pretty easy to get locked up to
yeah
approximation or something I'll you'll
see in a second but yes
now a few things to to highlight in
terms of assumptions that we're making
let me highlight sort of why is this
weird stability assumption necessary
suppose in each period we observe an
arrival of type either one or two
and we need to accept or reject them
and we are told and it's true the
probability in each period is one half
independently so we have IID arrivals of
type one or two and we want to maximize
over a known Horizon of length t
the maximum of X1 and X2 that we accept
subject to a budget of accepting at most
T over 2 arrivals
this is an incredibly stupid problem let
me highlight that first of all
like it's a very silly problem basically
what I'm saying is the two types are
exactly equal
a probably in the sense of in each
period probability is independently
one-half for either one to show up
you're allowed to accept in total T over
two of them
and your objective is to maximize
the maximum that you accept of either
type
now what's nice about this problem is it
sort of shows us why we need the
stability assumption
because
if I have more arrivals of type 1 than
of type 2
then the optimal solution will be to
only accept type 1 arrivals and it will
get
basically by setting X1 equal to T over
2 it will get an objective of T over 2.
if I have more arrivals of type 2 it's
the same story
this fulfills all of the things that we
want to fulfill it's lip [ __ ] it has
exchangeable actions it's IID the only
thing that's missing
is O2
and The Clairvoyant is always guaranteed
T over 2
but basically the best thing any
algorithm can do is commit to either
type 1 or type 2 always accept them and
with probability basically one half you
will lose square root T in expectation
so this is an example that shows the
stability assumption it looks like a
weird assumption it's actually necessary
to get all of one loss if you're going
to drop it you won't in general be able
to get the kind of guarantees that we
want
there are alternatives to it in
particular for overbooking
so in the overbooking setting where we
wanted to maximize this quantity here
I don't actually know how the optimal
solution changes when I put up my
arrivals
there are weird things you can imagine
that could happen where you accept one
more of one type and then you accept for
less of another and then you accept
eight more of yet another
it's sort of
um
weird to wrap one's head around it
but what one can do is one can restrict
oneself to a particular set
of solutions
in particular what we call index
Solutions
that order by the value of a type
divided by the probability of being
inertial
if you've seen the greedy heuristic for
one-dimensional knapsack where you
basically order by
density of value per size that's sort of
the
um in expectation equivalent version
and then we would accept lower index
types first
in general that's not Optimum so this no
matter these numerical results here sort
of show for a particular example
um the loss that you can get from that
um oh not the loss but sort of show you
what the optimal solution would do
versus what the index solution would do
but
what we can show
is that it only costs your constant
and once you've restricted yourself to
these index Solutions
you can basically prove this assumption
for the restricted set of index
Solutions
so the optimal solution might move by a
lot I don't know
but the optimal index solution will not
move by a lot
under a perturbation of the arrivals
and given that I can also bound the loss
of only considering index Solutions I
can basically decompose my loss of the
entire time Horizon by first saying
let's restrict ourselves to only index
Solutions let's take the hit of O of 1
and thereafter our assumption holds
so you do need something here it doesn't
have to be exactly the version that we
reflect in but you'll need something
that sort of keeps the optimal solution
stable
now before I get to actual algorithms
and results and proofs
I want to show some numerical results to
convince you that these algorithms are
actually reasonable algorithms
so here I'm showing you uh sort of very
silly bin packing instance with just two
types
two and three the bin sizes are of size
nine
with probability three quarters we
observe two one quarter we observe three
the green line is our algorithm the red
line you can think of as what's often
viewed as the state of the art the sum
of stress algorithm as you can see some
of squares on the lock lock plot goes up
ours stays constant
here's a slightly more complicated
instance
um
that is looked at also in a recent work
or recently published not so recent that
it was first discovered by Gupta and
radovanovic where you observe we stay
constant
um they also compared to some of squares
and on this particular instance their
algorithm does worse than sum of squares
and some of squares again is growing
whereas we stay constant so for bin
packing we get results that beat the
state of the art
admittedly our constants are problem
dependent and existing results don't
have this problem dependence that should
be a clear disclaimer
um here's sort of a much less
well-behaved problem that comes from
this job assignment setting that I
mentioned earlier I don't want to go
into too much detail what I want to
highlight is in this problem here we
looked at real data from credit card
transactions that is not well behaved so
like this data that comes from here is
uh there's not a constant number of
types uh so like we we don't necessarily
know here that this would behave well we
also observe something very weird which
is like it's first increasing then
decreasing which can happen on real data
high-level takeaways
um we do still get constant performance
and here we observe and overbooking this
is relative loss rather than absolute
loss
that we do scale linearly meaning
um our loss skills as one over T
relative to the total objective which is
equivalent in relative loss in absolute
loss there's constant loss
okay
so these algorithms seem to work let's
see how they work and why they work
now
we want to match against this
Clairvoyant that knows all the arrivals
aprily
for analysis purposes it's actually
useful to Define what I call a semi-club
Orient that follows the algorithm up to
a certain period
meaning
after 10 periods I've made some
decisions and The Clairvoyant the
semic-levant is forced to also adapt all
of these decisions but then from then
onwards
The Clairvoyant does what is optimal
from then onwards so notice
in this constraint here
I'm basically forcing the
semi-clairvoyant to follow the actions
that the algorithm has taken
and I want to sort of compare this
with what my fluid approximation as Elon
predicted would be doing
which solves the deterministic problem
in which the remaining arrivals are
replaced by the expectation
or a proxy for their expectation
for right now let's assume that we are
in the case where arrivals are IID and
known like the distribution is known
will get away from that in a little bit
so in this case
I would want to
if I solve the deterministic problem I
would want to sort of salt solve the
same maximization
but rather than having the true arrivals
I know my arrivals up until now
plus the expected arrivals
in the future
need to write T minus t a lot and I'll
just write T bar for that
now what I can do with this
is I can create a lower confidence bound
I claim on the number of times
that an action is played by the
semi-clairvoyant
for the following reason
I know with high probability and I'm not
mentioning all the constants that should
go in here so like from now onwards
basically whenever there's a one imagine
that there's a one with a bunch of
constants attached to it
I know with high probability
that for all of my different types
the number of arrivals that occur in
reality over the remaining Horizon
is somewhat close
up to whatever fluctuation there is to
the expected number of arrivals
and I also know and this is my weird
stability of optimum assumption
that there's an optimal solution that
The Clairvoyant might pick
that is at least
as for each action would look like the
deterministic one
minus some parameter Delta that is that
comes from the assumption
multiplied by how far my types are away
from what they really are now I don't
know how far they are away but I know
they are at most
square root T Bar Times log T bar right
so I know for every action
the existing semi-clervant solution that
uses it at least as often
as my deterministic solution would do
minus
this error that comes from well I don't
know the exact arrivals
so I need to increase some loss for uh
having
some error in the prediction versus the
real number of rabbits
one way to think about this is
there's some solution
that is the clairvoyant
and there's some solution that is this
deterministic problem that I'm solving
those two are different because they
have different parameters as inputs
but coming from this solution I can
create a lower confidence bound
and with high probability this lower
confidence bound will be below
the real number here
now
if
so I don't I don't know the optimal
solution
but with high probability
foreign
following this argument here
with high probability if I subtract from
my deterministic problem
basically for each action Delta Times
Square Root T Bar log T Bar
then with high probability there exists
a semic-levant solution
where each action would be above the
lower confidence form by the way for
some actions this may very well the
lower confidence Bond might be at zero
in that case it's it's not a very useful
one the lower confidence bond is
basically a lower confidence bound on
how often an optimal solution takes this
action in response to this type over the
remaining Horizon
[Music]
and it really only assumes the stability
it really assumes
but in different data and then the
solution which differs by that much
so to be clear this is some term on the
one hand it carries a lot of rate here
on the other hand by linear programming
perturbation results for a lot of
natural problems it will always work
um now
here's sort of a
a not super complicated
or Lemma now
suppose this lower confidence bound that
I've just constructed for every action
and every type
suppose those all hold true
given the current period
and now some periods transpire time goes
by
and over those periods I observe
arrivals I take actions
and now sometime in the future
I look at well
how often have I taken each action
let's assume that sometime in the future
for each action I'm still under the
lower confidence part
then I claim that the semi-clairvoyant
at that point in the future that is now
forced to follow my actions up to that
point
is still able to achieve the same
objective
that the semi-clairvoyant was able to
when I constructed the lower confidence
funds
why is that true because the
semi-clervoyant wants to get up here for
this action
I've already gone up here it's still
possible to get up there
wants to get up here for this action
I've already gone up here it's still
possible to get that
so as long as I don't violate my lower
confidence bounds and as long as my
lower confidence bounds actually hold
true
I'm guaranteed that the
objective that was previously previously
achievable by the semi-clervant will
still be achievable
that allows me
to basically prove my loss guarantee
I'm going to write
my loss as follows
I take the expectation of the loss
and I'd say well
in a sense
this is the semi the optimal solution is
the semi-clairvoyant at the beginning of
the Horizon which is unrestricted by any
decisions that I've made already
and the algorithms performance is the
semi-clervant at the end of The Horizon
which is restricted by all of the
decisions that I've met
I can basically use a telescoping some
to decompose this difference based on
all of the periods
in which I've created new lower
confidence bounds
and say well look at the difference
between what the club semi-clervoyant
was able to achieve at the beginning and
at the end
of these periods
well in those periods
if my lower confidence bounds were
correct I did not incur any loss at all
if my lower confidence bumps were wrong
the worst thing that could happen
is that I incurred a loss of L in every
single one of the periods
but then the probability of the lower
confidence bonds being wrong
is something like 1 over the remaining
number of periods cubed
so if we multiply this here we get
something like 1 over the remaining
number of periods squared at worst
so this whole thing
will sum up to a constant
now this assumed known IID distributions
this assumed non-time Horizon
will actually see that the changes
needed to get the other results are not
that significant so this main idea will
still hold true this main idea you've
also seen by set on Friday if you came
to a stock
presented admittedly in a very different
framework and mindset but I would say
it's the same main idea
so that's our first path to uniform loss
the only thing that I've not shown is
that we only need to solve log T times
um
after each resolving
basically I claim that for each type
um we
actually let me argue differently in
order to claim the log lock T times I
need to show that after I've resolved at
some given
with some given number of periods left
a sub-linear number of periods needs to
be left before I resolve resolve again
now you can think of this as being about
a budget of actions so how many actions
can I take for a given type
before I next observe an arrival that
for which I would be violating the lower
confidence Bond
and
it turns out that it's sort of not too
hard to see that that would be sub
linear in the current number of periods
left
and realizing that I am running out of
time so let me try to go a bit faster
second setting unknown Horizon
known IID distribution
in a sense there's a natural stochastic
policy one would be using
if one doesn't know the time Horizon
which is
look at the
um objective
and
look at the The Clairvoyant
and just replace it by the expectation
you don't know this expectation
but because you don't know T but you
know P Theta
and that basically allows you to still
solve for this stochastic policy
um here I'm using implicitly that f is
homogeneous
and
I can then say in a similar sense to
where I said before that there's a lower
confidence bound on the optimal Solution
on the optimal Clairvoyant solution
there's an upper confidence bound on how
often my stochastic policy will take
each action
skipping over a lot of math here as long
as my upper confidence bound on the
stochastic policy taking each action
is below my lower confidence bound
of The Clairvoyant taking each action
I'm guaranteed that I don't incur any
loss
and basically what I then use this as
long as I learn about the end of the
time Horizon sufficiently early
I can always guarantee that at the time
at which I learned about the end of the
time Horizon I have not taken any action
too early I've not taken any action too
much
so that gives us the unknown
uh time horizon or a probably unknown
timerism
again still assuming known IID arrivals
now what changes if our
arrivals are IID but the distribution is
not known
in that case it gets very tricky to
create lower confidence bounds for the
optimal solution because I don't know
P Theta I also maybe don't know T So
Right really I know neither
neither of these parameters
um
one good thing is that at least
initially I can compare to the
stochastic policy
because I've just seen that the
stochastic policy at least at the
beginning won't incur any loss relative
to the semicolon
now one natural thing to do is in Period
T just solve this deterministic problem
assuming sorry
assuming that the arrivals follow the
empirical distribution so far
now the empirical distribution so far
after T periods
will be close
in the same sense to before to the
real distribution
and that means that the optimal solution
to this one here and the optimal
solution to this one here actually also
somewhat close
so if we condition on this as being a
good event then we would like to just
follow this solution here and be
fine
but that doesn't actually quite work
and the reason is
that
if we solve this one here and we get
something that's small
think one over square root of t
act one might actually be equal to zero
according to the true stochastic policy
this event holds true
but this one here is still greater zero
with this one here would be equal to
zero
and because of that we need to do some
thresholding to avoid taking such an
action here
and basically there's a little bit of
technical detail needed to show that in
doing the thresholding
we sort of need to scale other actions
up
and we need to make sure that this
upscaling other actions up will not lead
to us actually violating
the lower confidence bound of The
Clairvoyant for these other actions
um
I won't go into the necessity of like
why you need to know sufficiently early
before the end but similar to The
Assumption or two uh you also need such
an assumption it doesn't have to be this
this exact one
this is one assumption that can be
plugged in
um also our lower bounds on the
probabilities
um if you allow arbitrarily small
probabilities it becomes impossible to
uh obtain the uniform loss guarantees
um
and in the interest of time let me
actually summarize with sort of the
results that we've gotten from this
framework
uh for specific problems
um first for overbooking
there had been some results that had
looked at sort of overbooking including
in cases where there is network of
Revenue management rather than just a
single resource
all of which got at best square root T
loss
um and that been some results including
uh earlier work by Alessandro alotto and
itsygovic and uh sit and Alberto Vera uh
that got constant loss in network
Revenue management was out of a bucket
so
the overbooking results that I basically
flashed at would extend in this
direction so they get o of one
for a setting with overbooking though
without the network
and that's based on work with kamasi
who's in the audience
um for bin packing uh this table I stole
from you and Lee from last year
basically there are a lot of results
that all achieve Square Rooty or Square
Rooty log t
um for different versions of online
stochastic band packing
all of them to be clear sort of make
different assumptions and arguably uh
weaker assumptions than we do
we get this constant loss
but with the big caveat that it's
problem dependent
um and this is based on joint work with
it
uh yes it would be dependent on the
item probability arrival
it would be dependent on uh
if I'm perfectly honest the biggest
piece that it's dependent on is all of
these results here
you tend to see something where the B
the
bin size
is a well-behaved
sort of constant like it's the B shows
up as just B and sit and I in our result
don't have a nice bound on what this B
how it would show up
so this constant M might hide something
that's exponential in b
but constant in t this is for one
distribution
also far now unknown as long as it's
discrete and as long as each arrival
type is not too rare
um
in terms of modeling as I mentioned
before I am a
quite a big fan of this idea of the
heads up for the Horizon and I think
it's a nice in-between sort of the
adversarial the stochastic and the known
setting uh and one thing that's nice is
that the positive results that we get
are comparable to what one would get if
we just knew the Horizon at Prairie
um and as I mentioned I would view it in
many applications as the most realistic
um
in terms of the lens of exchangeable
actions
the nice thing about this framework is
that it allows us to capture a wide set
of problems
not all problems of course so in
particular as I mentioned when I was
going to be talking in a little bit
about a set of problems where it would
not hold generally when there are
arrivals and departures as is often the
case in inventory problems that would
not work
um and our results for the most part are
instance dependent which is not
like my preference of course but at
least for some of the problems we
consider for example over booking we can
show that it's provably unavoidable
um
so to summarize we can view these
exchangeable action models as an
algorithmic and analytical framework
where we see how different sets of
assumptions would give us constant
regret we get new guarantees for the bin
packing problem and this overbooking
problem and while we don't have the
minimum set of assumptions we do get in
a sense a minimal set assumptions uh and
I'll stop here and be happy to take any
questions thank you
thank you
so here you're getting a constant regret
by making a stability assumption suppose
you don't have stability but as a
function of growing unstability do you
know how the record
uh
I think uh I I have to be honest I'd
have to look at the paper I think it's
either linear or quadratic it's not like
it's not like uh two to the data okay it
has to stop at square root I guess
in Europe
that are the various citizens
because we are sort of treating it as a
Content we're not being super tight at
every boat that we're taking so it might
be that it's linear in t just because
the the guarantee that will proof is not
perfectly tight
um but yes you're right we like to
there's only so much loss that you can
imagine
and as I mentioned very earlier like
getting square root T is like if you
knew the problem is super non-stable as
for example this maximum of X1 and X2
yes then
you should be using our algorithm and
you should just
use what's optimal there which will give
physical to us
um do you think there is value in
getting approximation ratio of results
probably
probably no and the reason is that you
can think of the constant regret as a
one minus o of one over T approximation
ratio so
so I mean there's always a space for
everything so if the assumptions that
we're making clearly clearly do not hold
then you may want to just use like
something more robust that has a
competitive ratio where you're more
certain that you will get some guarantee
if you believe that the sort of
assumptions that we hold either hold
true or at least approximately how true
then you may want to get this here
and again like that's
yeah I would say when these assumptions
hold them like
this is about as good as you can
also depends on whether our growth
um
that would not usually be a problem
I mean I I actually I should pick up
um if
I guess you could achieve zero and still
be within a constant of art so yes
you're right in that case a two
approximate like the competitive ratio
of two would be let us say yes I could
you if Ops is going to be
really smart if I'm just going to be
constant then you in that case if you're
just talking about additive start
application and it is still the same
thing right it's not like
competitive ratio is going to give you
something much more insightful than such
a difference between
so and this t to the three over four
time window that you ask
is that like square root is okay or if I
was very very careful about the analysis
I could get square root t log t with the
appropriate constant
uh with t to the one half plus Epsilon I
don't need to be careful but I need to
carry an Epsilon around
with t to the three quarters I can be
very comfortable
but yeah yeah it's that is really like
uh that was for Simplicity at the top
maybe one more question and then we can
break
just make sure it was necessary to have
uh the female like a low bound on item
arrivals yeah concept number of guys yes
and that's not only for for bin that's a
problem yeah
foreign
thank you